الأيدي الصغيرة تتشبث بأيادي أكبر من
شأنها أن تعطي أي شيء فقط للحفاظ على
سلامتها
، ووجوه باردة صغيرة نعسان وأذرع متعبة
، وطنين الأصوات التي تتوقعها
من عدد الأشخاص الموجودين هنا ،
لا وجود
لها كما لو أن الصدمة وعدم التصديق قد
جلبتا  مع ذلك صمت غريب
معظمهم من النساء والأطفال هنا
الذين اضطروا إلى توديع الأزواج.
لقول
إنها كانت تبكي
ومن ثم هناك الجحيم المطلق
للوصول إلى هنا
مشيًا لساعات الانتظار في بعض الحالات
لأيام في البرد القارس
جائعًا عطشانًا
نلتقي بأجمال وعائلته الذين فروا من
أفغانستان وقد حصلوا على حق اللجوء في
أوكرانيا لمدة سبع سنوات.  ابنتي تبلغ من العمر بالكاد
تصنعها هنا
مروة
أنا أروى أروى أوه ، هل هذا مشابه ، مرحباً
مروة ، الجو بارد جدًا
وتصيب ابنتي بالصدمة
ونحن نناديها بأنها لا
تجيب وأخيراً حاولنا التواصل مع
في سيارة الإسعاف ، وجدنا سيارة الإسعاف ،
يأتي الطبيب
فقط
لفحصه وبعد ذلك أعطونا فرصة
لا بد أنه كان كذلك ،
نعم ، تمسك بواحدة من الحيوانات المحنطة المتبرع بها
لتحل محل واحدة مماثلة تركتها
وراءها
ولكن من سيعطيها بقية
لقد عادت حياتها
ولكني لا أعرف بدون مستقبل معروف
مرة أخرى
على الأقل هذه المرة على عكس السنوات الماضية ، حيث
ترحب أوروبا باللاجئين ،
هناك تراكم غير إنساني هائل على
الجانب الأوكراني ، ولكن مرة واحدة أخيرًا هنا
في بولندا ، هناك جيش من المتطوعين
في القطار  ماكسين البالغ من العمر سبع سنوات
يدفن وجهه في ساقي والدته ،
لم يعتاد على الحشود ،
كل شيء مخيف ومربك ،
لقد انتظروا يومين كاملين
والدتك
هنا تمزقها ولكن على الأقل
زوجها غير الأوكراني خرج
معها كيف تقول وداعًا
لحب حياتك والد أطفالك
هذه المرأة ليست الوحيدة في البكاء ،
كما أن الآخرين لا يريدون التحدث بشكل مفهوم ،
لا يمكننا تحمل ذلك
يجعلنا نبكي كثيرا يقولون
أروى دامون سيينا شيميشي بولندا